all right and we are finally
live after some craziness but
the campfire still rolls on lord cognito
and ibontis
friday morning back on schedule how we
doing sir
oh we're doing pretty good and you know
work is always a little crazy the
world's a little crazy
uh yeah things are just crazy but you
know video games still a good place
keeping us busy uh the stream that got
to watch me
get to stream as much this week kind of
been doing some youtube videos and stuff
working on that but
no it's like i would say i got to play
some ghost this week and the one stream
everybody got to watch
it probably looked like a dark souls
stream as many times as i died
what was killing you uh so i don't know
if you're at the point where you have
the duals
because i also turned it up to lethal
difficulty oh see there you go with your
your dark souls
i turned it up the lethal and so far
since i turned to lethal i had like
i died a couple times here and there and
i was like yeah that was probably my bad
but it's actually felt pretty good
getting like
a single like slash or two on some guys
and the fights feel good
the duels like the five duels and then
the sixth duel
have you done that one you talk about
the straw hat guys
yeah the five straw hat guys and then
the sixth one for the very specific like
armor you get from it i'm not
i've only killed about three of them one
like like a champion
one of the farthest northeast area
he ruined me for a while and then the
leader of those five
worse wow so on lethal difficulty well
on lethal difficulty they can one tap
you
really one hit because it's like okay
it's dodging the blocking you can parry
the blues
and you can like block some but if you
don't dodge right
done yeah i died so many times i mean
for a samurai game being slashed with a
sword
on a big giant swing yeah i mean it
makes sense but it makes sense
but on the other side it's also like
damn i died a lot
that's the most i've died even like puts
anything else in this game of shame
probably ko tilcon's not even gonna be
remotely that bad
yeah i'm sure i had dudes get busy and
um
yeah man i don't even wanna know what
that is what happened
he said i was watching that was watch us
kind of follow this right
like like if somebody goes back on that
stream and clips i'm like ah
like i'm doing one of those things just
in frustration because i got the final
guy down to like
like that much like three times
did you have any um resolve at that
point
it was like so low no you start with one
in the first place so it's hard to build
any against them at all
so then like you take you if you don't
get one hit
he'll do like a sweeping move that i
swear always seems to damage me
sometimes i'm always healing a little
bit
no it's like it almost had to be a
perfect fight almost
when it went perfect actually felt
really good because i'm like dodge
dodge whoosh like back up and roll like
it feels really good when they nail it
right like
like it felt so when you get the perfect
parries in that game
open them up yo you feel good you get
that
the combat is lit like at some point we
will do like a full
yeah goes to sushi but like bonus last
word because
yeah we're still we're both still
working through so i got to see how it
ends and stuff uh but yeah
horizon zero dawn pending we got the
avengers beta that starts on playstation
today
i don't know when i'm gonna get to any
of these things but yeah what have you
been doing man
me man actually back to destiny yeah i
played a lot yeah i played a lot this
week um shout out to attic because um
he's got shout out to forte who hooked
attic up with a better graphic card so
he actually played destiny consistently
because carl was dying so we lost one of
our major raid guys so
shout out to um sinister attic the whole
team cat daddy if you in there that we
was in there man and uh
we're starting our we're starting our
moments of triumph
raid stuff so we did leviathan prestige
getting that going and yeah it's been a
while since
i did that man it was it's been a while
i was like yo
you know what surprise surprising i
always dread gauntlet
yeah and i'd never never that bad before
i never ran before oh through the
circle never really so what they were
telling me like yo prestige
car you know you gotta run i'm like
everybody knows yeah
no they say no you have to do it and i'm
like all right so let me do it for
did i end up loving running i'm like yo
yeah yeah i was like yo this is fun like
so yeah like i never ran before so shout
out to prestige for forcing the
mechanics
the other thing is addict is really good
at dogs
the problem is he never did prestige and
i believe there's two
extra dogs and it was throwing them off
and the raise a little glitch yeah i
gonna lie like the dogs are
like this they're spotting you if you're
up top like it's
really glitchy i was like the people who
know dogs
who like guide you like don't know go
here people who know dogs well
it's impressive to watch because they
almost have like the pattern like
perfect
he's a machine but because of the two
extra dogs yeah it was throwing them all
so we did that
um yeah surprise dogs are the longer
bathers we were kind of messy but we had
we did so much dps to the
to the lanterns those are out of there
and then uh big daddy callus
that's always my fun i always love love
that fight going from the plates
going in and out of the shadow run yo
leviathan was a fun raid i i really i
really do like it so what we're gonna do
is we're doing them in sequence
we'll do either we're gonna try to do
either this weekend if not we'll start
at the beginning of next week
so each week each week we got that we
got a little ray team going and just get
scared get scared
in there for you you almost solo it
trying to solo it and stuff like that
and i saw it like he popped up with like
14 million damage or something like that
i was like i've seen other solo and he's
working on some of that stuff right now
yeah dude beast oh shout out to eric all
right oh i'll definitely call on you for
aspire because spire means a lot i would
love
to get sleeper catalyst that that is the
bane of my existence i've run it a few
times
and everybody else gets it
well maybe they'd cranked up the drop
rate if you finish it maybe it's just
there
i just watch if you do i want let me
know if i'm around
cause i wouldn't mind trying for that i
don't love i don't like
direly want spires i did my spire all i
need is actually leviathan to finish
mine i did the rest so
we next sequence for fortes and then
we'll do uh eater
which i never beat i got to the boss
eaters wanted like a great boss fight
yeah
i just had terrible teams around that
time and i never got a chance i never
got back to it
so yeah then we'll do what you call and
then there's two the other raid that i'm
looking forward to later down the road
is crown which i've never done
never done ground seriously yeah off the
resume yeah
crowd trying to think how to explain
crown
it feels hectic but with a well
organized
like a well-oiled machine like because i
ran with um
i ran with glasgow thanks to aries like
i got to run with some of them and yeah
if you have the right person running it
and somebody who's like aware for
callouts because like i've only done it
maybe twice in that boss fight there's a
lot of cause you're you're switching a
buff back and forth the whole time you
have it
and you got to make sure you switch it
so the other person gets it so you're
always able to damage like half the ass
it's like a buff that you have to yeah
half the team has a buff half the team
doesn't because some ads are
immune to half the team and then vice
versa
so like both sides always have to be
able to do something and then there's
crystals that have to be shot by
each person like one with and one
without the buff to break
so you have to be kind of doing that
stuff the whole time and the biggest
pieces
and like just watching the way it was is
just the reminder be like hey let's
switch the buff
let's go ahead and stay on and it's just
like if people you can stay up with like
kill in the ads
and kind of know the sequences yeah it
can run really it can run really smooth
but yeah it's like i tried crown
for when it came live i think i did it
blind when we were starting
and i probably spent six five six hours
on the first encounter
wow and we didn't even beat it when we
were trying when we tried blind the
first time and then i jumped
that was our guy no how many counters
yeah uh
it's mainly the opening a little jump
um just jump like cooperative shooting
of crystals
and then a two phase it's all in the
boss room it's short
okay okay not the biggest thing in the
world i think that's all it is there's
it's not that long at all like three i'm
actually looking forward to i'm actually
looking forward to
the ones i'm looking forward to the most
is i will admit eater when i
remember when i remember it being fun i
remember cooking up the craniums and
doing some stuff with that
yeah you know but yeah i'm really
looking forward to last wish that that's
gonna be so fun to do that again
and um what you call it uh i need
falling mods
and uh for uh what you call it scourge
so
yeah yeah i need to try and make sure i
pay attention to the raid groups that
might be running scourge for those uh
all it is is the sparrow run yeah that's
the only place for that chest so if you
find some fair runs
yeah it's the only place to drop wow
interesting but if you get the
checkpoint right
get the checkpoint just do three sparrow
runs that's all you need for the mods
yeah
if you got anarchy at least mm-hmm yeah
i think shout the [ __ ] he got he got
anarchy i'm jealous
all right that's what's up what we got
uh nothing too much going on right now
right
yes zero zero zero going on
no we got uh kind of two
at least things from bungie we got a
fairly early twab
mostly because they dropped all the news
about solstice of heroes
uh so we got the trailer about the event
not a huge surprise obviously we're
going back to the european aerial zone
got a look at some of the armor that
we'll earn like kind of go through all
what it takes to get that stuff
feels similar to last time with some
tweaks uh from what you've seen so far
feeling good feeling same feeling i
don't know if i'm gonna grind what do
you think
feeling the same um
[Music]
i said at first i was like i don't know
if i'm gonna grind at first
sort of almost and i'm like okay all
right now i will say
hunters y'all got it hunters to me
they got it this one oh yeah i'm not
sold on the warlock helmet
it's something warlock's talked to me am
i bugging like is there something
off with the solstice one i don't know
and let me ask you a question um yours
is like
yours doesn't look bad oh no i just
don't mind looks
yours has more going on than mine mine
looks like my basic visor
chrome dome helmet yeah and it's got
some we got like maybe a little thing up
top
yeah your helmet looks a little more
fancy than mine i'm sitting here looking
at the pictures mine looks
mine looks very normal for a helmet i
mean they all look ornate
but at least the haunted look
i love do you like the cloak or the helm
i like
the the the cloak i like the chest
plate i like it it's just something
about it with the rap like it's some
hunter's is lit on this one i feel i
don't feel that the warlocks is just
terrible it's just something seems
missing to make me
love it that's what i feel it it's
average it's not it's not like
you know so that's that's like affecting
my grind a little bit
yeah like a smaller version of it it's
like i got these little baby horn i
don't know it's something like
off about the warlock well how do you
feel about this titan one
uh well it's always like the they'll
show the female titan i guess because it
was the male titan it would like dwarf
the other two
if you put them next to each other
they'd be like man that's beefy boy over
there
uh so i mean the shoulders look small
like overall i mean i enjoy the ornate
nature of these armors
that's why it's always been a bummer for
years that we haven't been able to carry
these things forward
which has been an issue yeah i feel like
the
i'm looking at the neck on the titan
though and it looks like a giraffe neck
got stretched
yeah cause it's like the hell yeah and
then like the plates here and then it's
like somebody's wearing
like a really like constricted
turtleneck or something like it's weird
the neck is a little weird i would agree
with that
uh i mean overall it's all like cool
stuff definitely enjoy
like the idea of the armor i'm looking
at trying to get an idea what the mark
looks like for
me i mean either for the armor they all
look cool because you got like
the light like busting out kind of
cracking through you got the gold and
silver metals and the metallics and like
the dark cloth underneath the contrast
they all look cool like if you if you're
going to walk around in armor
there's about 50 other sets that
probably look worse than these
so there's definitely some good stuff in
here for sure shout out to witchcraft
incognito
yeah it does give me nasty but it looks
like a a low budget nazarick sin
like nazareth's got the the nice pointy
it's like callouses
or x and it's all blinged out that kind
of looks like a
baby bobblehead yeah yeah
it just needs something yeah
especially the white light like not like
the base one
or the color but the one with the white
glows that neck is
all sorts of like clip yeah yeah it's a
little too long it's a little too
little long in the neck i was like maybe
for you on the warlock i'm actually
wondering because both the hunter and
the titan
the titans got like the black almost
like feather thing up top
the warlocks got the cloak but both of
the glows are horns
and then the warlock glow looks a little
more subtle because it almost matches
your horns maybe that's the way
because like the other two you got the
big glows like doing this whole thing
and yours looks almost like hidden by
the two like kind of yeah it's like
really but also like dude the v helm
i mean you may not like the big bug out
ears but the v helm shape in the middle
is the best of the three because
mine does look like the cracked visor
and like the hunter looks like kind of
at night with the thin slit
but dude that v helm looks cool it's
unique i mean it's unique
i'll say that i will say i got it maybe
i throw a shade on it it's unique it's
trash
it's seasoning it's unique again it's
not terrible
it's just average it's not it's i'm not
like jumping out my seat with it that's
all
well let's see let's see what's going on
you know what i'm saying but the hunters
man
i'm jealous like that hunter outstanding
i got it man
hunters look fly like i am digging that
whole aesthetic i was like so
here's the big question yes
when it comes to the armor as we have
learned from
mostly reading twitter actually i got
tagged on one that finally explained it
later on
so we know we'll get to the leveling of
the upgrades all that type of stuff yeah
you got the white glow
you can earn that one you got the colors
you got to pay for them go pay for your
colors brother
i was like thoughts on the color
versus free returns
do you have opinions over the eververse
controversy in this matter sir
i will say this i was surprised that we
didn't have to pay for them three times
per class i'm glad that
that's the start let's start more we
better it's not a hundred dollars we're
down to 45 now
we got a 45 now like that was ridiculous
and then
they they did say something about
the color and relation i know we'll get
into it deeper
yeah well we'll get into that yeah i got
a thought on that one
i want to i want to bring up but um they
did something to say something in
relation
to the glow after you buy it and then
what does it intensifies
as your super gets full as your super
gets right yeah so that's all
like the white glow yeah every every
glow will be more intense
when you have a full super okay that's
for you look
um with the glow i like that that was
glows free
you know with the cosmetic per class it
could have been cool and it would have
did it by default but then i think they
just don't want to separate
all of them by subclass and save them
money you know try to save us money so
to speak
i knew they were gonna cash out somehow
i just didn't know how they were gonna
cash out
yeah so this is like a so this is a
slight knifing not
not like all the way in you just like a
you know this is you know
pokey a little bit just to say hey we'd
be like hey if you want to look extra
you're you're flying that white but if
you want to look
extra you pay an extra if you want extra
you pay an extra buck there you go
you can look pretty good just if you
want to like call if you want to go from
black
you want to go monochrome you want to
get into the modern age with those
colors
yes yeah yeah that's what it is it's a
chat
it's a little listen once you hit the
atm a little bit all right so to be
clear for chat the white glow
is earned if you want the colors which
you only have to buy
one set per subclass so they will change
color based on your subclass but the
colors themselves
are the ones you buy from eververse
either with bright dust it's
probably data mind-ish guessing 6 000
percent right
and then silver everybody seems to guess
it's like 1500 silver so
for us like 15 15 bucks
uh but yeah bright dust would be about
6k so it depends
yeah shot the trams yeah it's business
you know they got to monetize you the
show tess hustler yeah tesla hustled out
there there for fed church for sure for
sure
yeah it's like tess hustling then ava
avanti's over here giving her free
cookies to keep those two like
nice she's like i'll bake you goods you
give me free stuff from your store and
then i'm going to sell to these people
for crazy numbers
they got that exclusives in here
what's up bruce how you doing um so yeah
that's one of the big things is
everybody's kind of like oh you got to
grind for this stuff you got to do this
the big controversy before was we got
all the grinding done
right we got the set of armor armor 2.0
came out talk about it
crap stat armor 48
trash like you can still get up to like
mid
60s a little better now something like
this
if you grind for these things which
we'll get to in a bit
it's some time in there and if you did
all three you want to lose your mind
so the fact that like we get here's your
starter set
those are like the worst stats you
literally allow on armor well that's
where you start
right i spent how long doing this i'm
having a conversation with myself over
here but
because you remember that crowd yeah so
this is a real grind so it is like it's
a step in the right direction that we
are going to be able to
use the p the armor for you know a year
basically since we do have a longer
season
uh and then also we know that you can
once you earn them a
magnificent i got to get the names right
the magnificent armor which is the one
with the white glow that's the
the top legendary once you master work
it and that's the way at least it said
it which is
weird thing but you can once you earn
that you can go back in the european
aerial zone and earn more
for chances at rolls so you can get
decent rolls of stuff that's gonna laugh
for a while
that's the key because see the thing
about it when they messed up that last
time was again you did all that grinding
and you're just stuck
with this default role of god knows what
and it was low stat
right so it just kind of it really i
felt your pain on it it really
you know defeated the whole purpose of
it because you you should if you do all
if you master work this armor
at minimum you should be giving me 60 to
65
you know at minimum right so you want
those those those those cool rolls and
stuff like that so yeah
i love the fact that they're almost
treating it like
comp when you unlock you know remember
when you get in comp you had unlocked
like rhetorics and
stuff and then you got a chance to keep
getting it back every time
you cash in a little bit so i like it
you know i'm saying this is this is
really cool
you know this is a nice welcome change
and for me
i it just made me finally delete
my old one you know i said because i was
holding on to it and i told you i still
have the package that
uh banshee i haven't picked up the
warlock package so it's been sitting
there for like a year
jesus that that indicator doesn't give
you ocd
he doesn't actually have it if why did i
go blurry yeah he would blur
focus can't focus focus hey i'm back
okay
i waved my hand in front of the camera
and it freaked out um
so you got the package jeans over there
i wouldn't say you're dumb just a sucker
for punishment oh if you know me at all
between dark souls
turning on lethal mode and ghost i'm a
suck i'm a glutton for punishment
apparently yeah that's you're not wrong
um yeah so it is like
last time around it hurt time before
it's happened as well
like we got our first like then it was
like solstice of heroes and then you get
armor now that has random rolls okay
well
this okay then we went armor 2.0 now
with all the mods
this is the first time armor's not gonna
change but that also is my one little
tweet that i put out
and i was like it's also kind of sad
because it literally
cements and we're not getting any major
armor changes for a good year
yeah i thought about you i saw your
tweet i saw your tweet and i
listen you're you're lord of armor
so i know this definitely it's different
um i was surprised i was surprised i
didn't i didn't i thought we'd get
some tweak to armor i didn't necessarily
expect a major one
but almost it's always always on the
lowest end of the totem pole man
yeah it's like they care so much about
the weapons and i'm not saying like
you know getting a whole new slew of
weapon perks and maybe
changing some stuff up there it's not
like that would be a bad thing so it'd
be something i mean you shoot the
weapons all the time you're looking at
them more frequently
that's how you play the game i kind of
get why they're a priority
but on the other side like armor is how
you build your character your builds
your stats which i still don't think the
stats matter
enough i can go through solo flawless
and as long as i have the mods i
my stats didn't matter which is kind of
sad like that you have stats that i
don't really care
now you can go through in pvp build and
go like full intellect full recovery
and it can feel definitely different
like you get your super faster as a
whole team you're gonna start stomping
on people
yeah but like it's just
it's cool you like as a chain what what
what would excite you what would get you
to be like you know what they're finally
taking armor serious
and and this is what i'm talking about i
mean like okay
so resilience i mean the idea to take
more damage literally by definition to
be more resilient
which is not how you define a word but
being able to sustain more of like an
onslaught of whatever's coming at you
if like 10 if you went 10 resilience in
a pve
activity like you should feel tankier
okay you should like hey if i go 10
resilience you know that boss that
normally takes off like half of my
health
he takes off a third like it's a
noticeable damage difference where you
can
you can take another sniper shot you can
do all those things that like
if you went heavy into resilience you
would do that for a grand master
nightfall
maybe it may be a slower playthrough i
don't reserve my intellect build as much
but if i go full resilience any
grandmaster nightfall when stuff wants
to kick the crap out of me just by
looking at me
right maybe it would be a little more
and then mobility
would be another one is mobility is like
it is only ads strafing and
mostly it and jump height i believe
you can you literally cannot run faster
in this game unless you wear an exotic
you could have 100 mobility and we're
going to run at the same speed in my
head that just breaks me
no i agree i agree and i think
i don't want an excuse for them but i
think part of it had to do with you know
the frames on the older consoles you
know and they maybe they'd not be able
to differentiate
speed differences and stuff like that we
had actually a couple of questions in
the chat right now so shout out to jason
he want
he said question if you actually need to
master work to get additional roles
so does this mean each piece you match
to work drops into the pool
so the way i read it and i'm just going
to go to their words not mine
so similar previous years you will start
with a rare set upgraded to a majestic
legendary set
once you have all your legendary gear
you can start a final set of objectives
to upgrade to a
magnificent set here's the look at the
objectives required
complete a nightfall or deal on master
complete a nightmare hunt which
that's like the easiest one of all
complete a bit of heresy win seven
trials matches
i haven't done that yet so two birds
with one stone for the seasonal stuff
and it doesn't happen and then complete
a tier five altar of sorrow
so those are the five you got to do i
think the sorrow of what you got to do
three times
yeah three times yep cuz that's easy
yeah just
people be hanging out there for a little
while completing these objectives will
unlock a white glow
on your armor you need to upgrade your
armor to majestic during solstice of
heroes
but you can continue to complete these
objectives like the master working after
the event ends
so if you get your legendary set the
masterwork isn't required until later
you can though continue to earn more
randomly rolled pieces of gear for your
magnificent
magnificent set in the eas
so now i don't know if you get the and
that's what it's like the majestic and
magnificent
i would picture maybe once you finish
the majestic
set and you're able to like work
on the masterwork objectives for the
magnificent
maybe you'll have magnificence but like
even if you go into
eaz you might get a drop that just
doesn't have the masterwork done
so you might be able to get one that's
not like glowing yet but you might be
able to get a magnificent armor
just doesn't have the glow yet and then
hopefully you can keep working on rolls
i'm hoping that way it works because if
you have to master work
completely everything to start getting
rolls that definitely seems to like yeah
that'll be hard for some people to take
advantage of that absolutely
seven trials wins so now we're in two
spots
they're putting people into trials
better dust them boots off baby what
boots
i don't i don't have i don't have trials
boots be like these are for trash i
don't have those i don't have trials
boots
you better get in there i'm gonna be
doing i'm gonna
reset a card get one win and be like you
guys just want to reset and go back yep
okay clean slate do it again i'm not
even gonna try for more than one win
probably because if you like go up at
all i'm just gonna i swear just like
two wins cheaters oh crystal come on i
hate that they foster this
you guys gotta play the game so here's
the issue it's not match made
right it is not a match made activity so
you're forcing people to literally go
so difficult to find two people these
days
how many people do you think play this
game casually or solo
and don't want to go into something that
they know currently right now is
renowned to have cheaters
absolutely absolutely absolutely i mean
but the thing is you guys do do uh
nightfalls and mass nightfalls is
there's no matchmaking there sir
there's lead mass making in legend
nightfall mm-hmm
no i was like i mean the master you got
to find a group too or you can solo you
literally
cannot solo trials you technically
if you were skilled enough you could
solo a nightfall
but you truly can't solo trials
crystal's upset pvp is the worst part of
the game
look if you want your glow you gonna
have to jump
and feed you gene's over there like
jeans over there like one reset one
reset yeah
but it's just like if you're gonna take
people into pvp i would rather have them
be like hey go do an elimination
just as an altercation
because it's just a match making sure it
just gives people the option for
matchmaking
as it's mostly related to pve pde pde
matchmaking if you want to master work
they're going to make you go find people
and time to make friends this is the
friend game i love how you're actually
being the bungee apologist right now
and yet i know in the back of your head
you're not you're saying i'm not wrong
just during the podcast not going to
play devil's advocate just to piss them
off
it's time to have friends y'all look we
look we all love what we love but hey if
you want that glow
if you want to shine you're going to
need to jump in there
so crystal we got we got this beautiful
thing called lfg let me explain it to
you right
it is so cool bungie has this thing and
you just like go
and you check it out and then they have
all these rooms and one says trials
right and then you say hey i'm one and i
need
two foot trials not trying to take it
too seriously oh you're telling me i
have to go to the internet to go play
the game thing that i don't play i gotta
go outside the game to do this thing
[Laughter]
hey i can't control the development
cycle with matchmaking let's see
now if you're on xbox you got that
interview it integrated into your ui
fozzie know what i'm talking about
yeah but that's a small that's the
smallest population of except stadia so
i mean
if you're gonna play that card i'm gonna
play that card
sorry game pass in november
won't matter later i'm just saying right
now that's not the biggest population
listen shout out to fosgety if you want
the leroy globe
he knows what i'm talking about that's
what you got to do man that's what you
got to do so look
it's fun don't take it seriously ain't
got to go to the lighthouse
you work on it you got beautiful people
lfg you got
awesome clan mates most likely you guys
go in there don't take it too serious
and then they got the new bounties for
you guys so you ain't got to win too
crazy
just get one and done just work on it
man i was like
they were okay they were doing so good
on a lot of the objectives do
this or this dude this or
this what if it was seven trials wins
or a master nightmare hunt yo the chat
is
bad yeah shut up the geek the titan will
get the glow
but i 200 think bungie needs to get his
head out of his rear
forcing people to do pvp especially an
activity without a play hub
to find other memories to do said
activity and have done
nothing to [ __ ] down that problem with
you the last part
i'm with you cheating part it's spooky
out there you know they out there doing
illegal maneuvers you know people with
their kds is so bad
that part i am so with you i'm never
gonna fight that part
i just i there's a part of me though
that does like the aspect look
i'll be honest when i played destiny in
the beginning i did not like pvp i never
was i was just pv exclusively i think it
was like thorn
one of them stupid quest that made me go
in there and you you
ended up starting to get a little flow
man you had to start appreciating we're
not saying
pvp is bad okay still saying pvp is bad
i'll take that back
but as like as jason said he's like
seven trials win or fabled in survival
make him maybe go do that but maybe
give him an option where it's not
because seven trials wins probably would
go faster
if you went fabled in survival that's
gonna take you longer but it is
something you could do
without especially with the freelance
playlist you could do without a team
so it gives just like no
understand the state of your game
especially on pc
and give people the alternative to where
there's cheaters anyway
don't force them into trials where and
it's only on the target awesome
oh listen alternative is awesome i'm
never going to be
not against alternative that that's dope
shout out to slow-mo he said forcing
people to
listen we have to be honest y'all this
is a
vanity glow this is not nothing bad
this is yah i want to be fresh so if you
want to be fresh
get in there you go still have you can
have everything glowing except that one
part that'll be dull
that will be the trials part of your
armor that you're not doing
that's all they say you know you still
go get you everything else that's not
it's not going to glow unless you get
them all
look all right let me confession the way
you guys are dreading
um trials i'm dreading that grandmaster
nightfall
i'm like good lord i'm not ready for
that well you don't have to do it on
master you don't have to do grand master
oh it's always bad but still i'm
dreading i don't really do master
nightfalls like that
so like that's what i'm dreading like i
don't and and then i gotta
jump in the dungeon again but peter
harrison is not too bad i was like i've
solo
pit i can walk you through it yeah i'll
jump in your backpack for that one
seven wins man that's all travis is
dreading bro
listen trials gotta try it gotta at
least try that there is a thing this is
a mode you
guys haven't even seen gotta see it see
what it's like
i've seen it experience it
gotta go do it so we also know when you
get your blue armor to go to the
legendary legendary to the other
we know this is a long grind yeah it's a
graph
last time when i did all three
characters before like armor 2.0 came
out
which is why i was so annoyed doing all
three characters getting your
you know however many 25 public events
you got to do or your
thousand orbs or 300 crucible kills i
mean
this stuff is like long time grinding oh
grindy grindy this is great let me tell
you right now
i dreaded that solstice grind i think
between
let me ask you this
now let me ask you this though between
this one
and um because this is moments it's
not what's the one we had to do where we
had to do the story missions
of the red war a bunch of times
originally
the story missions yeah what was that
one and they did that
commissions redux yeah which which event
was that y'all y'all remember what was
this two years ago this two years ago
two years ago so these are just that
that's why i have the ship on my hunter
that i do
which was also a grind but that's the
hunter ship that i have that
or at least is sitting on my hunter
because no like nobody has that ship
okay so that was first summer solstice
okay then they came back again
with what we had last year which is he
was last year
the aaz was like which was the debut and
now with easy again just for some tweaks
to
okay yeah i mean look this is a grind i
don't i remember going from blue
to purple was was was it was getting uh
the purple's not
purple you're like jesus what is all
this jesus christ like yeah
it it it's listen this is the perfect
event for them
during this time of nothing to do being
that the game got delayed
like so roughly data mine stuff yeah
sorry not spoilers this stuff's grindy
i'm just going to give you some details
and even if it's not right it's roughly
what it was last time so i'm sure it's
what we got the exclusive datamount on
the activities it's on reddit man
it's not just me let's get it so i think
this might be based on like the titan
armor and this is always where it's like
annoying
because like the title will be like go
get void orbs and strikes and i'm
playing with a warlock who's trying to
get arc orbs and strikes and you're like
competing you're like
dude what are you doing to me so yes
uh helm for example 10 gambit matches
okay grind the anointing a thousand
total orbs which that one's really not
that bad that's that's easy
guardians defeated with arc weapons 100
100 starts that up 10 heroic public
events
okay 20 bosses in eaz which you'll
probably do anyway yeah you'll do that
quick yeah
600 kills and strikes okay
300 300 fallen defeated okay
elemental final blows 2000.
playlist strikes you need void orbs for
a titan for the greaves
uh 100 solar melee final blows
i need five patrols on io 200 elemental
orbs
solar weapon final blows and the only
issue is as you're going to most of
these match made activities
you're usually going to bump into people
on other classes and if i need void they
probably need solar or arcs so you're
always
so like the general orbs you get really
fast and like the specific orbs you need
those take a while
the thing you always got to remember is
key with this event
is multi-tasking trying to do
the most efficient thing whether it be
strikes with a certain weapon with a
certain thing
also it's time to dust off exotics that
give you
proc double grenades double anytime they
want grenades and melee kills yeah time
to dust off them exotics
you know warlocks get your claws out
claws and amenkara
titans y'all know what to do y'all got
so many like solar melee final blows
do something like hallo fire heart
boost that thing up throw some melee
some strength mods on there if you're
going
like you really probably need to look in
your builds a little bit for some of
this stuff
you need 600 kills and strikes we also
need fallen go do fallen strikes with a
solar weapon
and that's probably the only three you
could probably do together there so like
try and look through all five at the
same time as you're saying yeah make
make this an efficient run otherwise
it's only good if you just go one dot at
a time oh please help me
question are they gonna do that thing
where we gotta have it on again
otherwise they don't count yeah they
will
you know they will it's the way it
worked before i don't know
so then you can't use your exotics to
work on your stuff it'll work
or if you or if you're like hey i'm not
going in again but right now i could
well no i gotta leave that on the case
look at that that's the part of the
noise because now you're not
optimal on these on these like these
things
and you you have to subtract exotic that
part's annoying
that's why it's always annoying that
it's it and it's like okay
give me five quests in my quest log
right not the armor related stuff yeah
like my thing is it should still count
if you don't
have it on it should still count the
progress should still continue like
them forcing the suit and we're all
looking like
simple simons with the same stuff on and
you know what i'm saying like that that
annoys me like
that's my little pet peeve i've always
you know whatever but
yeah titans like titans with dune
marchers get multiple kills yeah but you
need ark
you need solar melee kills and those are
arc so again
like they some of the stuff like will
synergize well then others you're like
this is like the slowest thing ever
today slowest thing ever yeah yeah
and then but here's the thing the cool
thing is finding
those activities where you could fall in
the hell out of
certain chills or whatever like you know
one thing community is good
at finding the hustles yeah they're like
yo go to escalation protocol do this
or go to this place and do that i mean
it's like that like guardian games
trained us well like
what is the most efficient build for all
the stuff but that one you usually just
needed
kills or something like that you need
elemental final blows
or void orbs in strikes it gets quite
specific at a point he gets very
specific at a point yeah
yeah and then the worst thing is when
you
do all that and you you you think you
made progress you checked and you didn't
make it oh god because
you looked at it wrong uh
when the wording was bad oh you couldn't
even figure out what they actually knew
and you oh man the nightmares of this
state they also have one whereas like
you needed
grenade launcher kills but it showed a
sub machine gun but you made progress
with the scout do you remember that
weird one
yes i don't even know i don't even know
what that was related to but somewhere
in the history there was like
you needed progress for something but
you actually the the quest showed
another thing
but actually made progress with the
third thing you're like
wait wait no but we're gonna get this
right you're gonna get this right
yeah please please just play the step so
nobody's like focus
proper verbage please please
icons correct please qa this thing y'all
just somebody give it a once-over and i
know
yeah trust me they look over the stuff
all the time and it was even like um in
a prophecy dungeon
they're like hey don't give qa a hard
time qa finds all this stuff
it's if they can get it he did it like
one of them said too and it was like
hey guys it's like qa finds all this
stuff and they're damn good and find it
fast it's like this decision
that look we gotta [ __ ] and then we're
gonna yeah
yeah it's not usually a time thing a
development cycle whatever it is when
it's like
they know it's there they can only do so
much and that's kind of that's the thing
with a live service game
continual like deadline approaches you
can only do so much you guys so much yep
that is a good point that was a great
part of that uh prophecy stream
mm-hmm yeah that was so cool still um
but yeah the grind is 100 gonna be that
yeah um how do you feel about eaz in
reference to i want to ask you a
question because kai
always talks to me about this i never
got your opinion in the eaz now you're
floating around and you do your boss
then you have that mystery egg hunt yeah
how do you feel about that i don't love
it
okay i'm okay not not a fan
it's just like
okay everybody pause and look and you're
with random people usually you're like
well i'm looking over here and this
guy's literally looking over my shoulder
we both go in the same direction i'm
like son of a [ __ ]
like it i under like you could make some
you could be like as you're running
around i wish like during it be like hey
there's a there's a bonus chest if you
like
went to go explore all the different
places where the bosses were hey
maybe every time there's a bonus chest
if you go exploring every well
and you get far enough along maybe one
spawns up for every five bosses and
says hey there's a hidden chest and
somebody actually finds it i would enjoy
that more
than the here they are go find them go
find it
because like you can look and some
people like okay no that one's like down
below and behalf of people don't know
you gotta go through a bus to go
underground to find that weird funky one
um yeah somebody's like there's a good
reddit article about route
you should take to find them all and
that's i i get that
to a point but on the
other side i mean what do you think am i
crazy to think that i'm like
hey i go through i killed like oh we got
nine bosses
sweet it was actually a pretty good run
but then we turn around and you're like
i have two morons to win in the same
direction i did i'm like well that was
kind of waste
it is a little it's a unique mechanic at
first i thought it was fun it does get
annoying and then the only thing that
the only that bothers me
is the proximity mechanic because
sometimes
it shows up or it doesn't show up and
you think you're close and you know that
whole kind of thing so it is
it's just weird that they would put
something like that in the game i've
never really seen them do that except
this and they do it tight timing yeah if
you had maybe like one more minute to
look
because it's it's like you have maybe
two minutes to find them all but some
you're like oh i'm here
well is it through the wall no i gotta
go around to the other side of the
building
and it's just that weird it was always
felt like you have to
you work hard to try and picture so try
and rush almost too much like
if you work really hard yeah if you kill
like 14 bosses like somebody like glad
you're gonna have a chest probably
everywhere you go
and just make a big circle but if you
kill like five and you go over here and
you get like one and you're like
why is nobody else picked up a chest and
you're waiting for the little activity
feed to pop and nobody's finding
anything and you're like
well i committed over here because i
know this one's screwy nobody else got
anything you're like
so i don't know if i love it because
it's always like
oh it's kind of a fun adventure go find
him every time and after a while you
tend not to care about them
but it's still until they start tying
requirements to them yeah you need to
have like 10 chests or 10 packages or
something and it's what you get from
those
don't remember the bosses remember
knowing we had to do tricks
just to do we had to do spawn respawning
of a
ball uh what you called to come down and
farm
boy because the boss requirements were
so out of range
and ridiculous they really misjudged it
the first time around i mean last time
yeah
mm-hmm uh i was actually gonna look and
see
yeah zero time that's gonna be the wave
you already know
i've had my wigs on you already yeah it
says like 20 bosses
but that's like main bosses depending on
what you face so i don't know what it
was before
it was like 100 bosses everybody's like
oh hell no so that may be the farm so i
don't know what number it was
yeah yeah like a chest room or
just something like it doesn't need to
be you already get done running around
this place and you're like trying to get
up to a boss
who's on a rooftop and you're like well
i'm down here on the bottom but there's
no shelf meeting up so i gotta run over
here jump on this little curtain jump up
fly across try and get to the guy
and it's like the verticality of it's
not bad because there's actually i wish
there was more verticality in the game
generally yeah actually don't
mind that i like it but when you force
me to try and then go
vertically in a game that's not overall
built for it per se
as well we have at least the mantling
but
i don't know i just like hunting for
like chest over here and over here and
it's like yeah you get a feel for
where they're at and i'll probably start
to get efficient at it again i'm
probably gonna not know at first but
i wonder if there's still going to be
one down on the bus yeah
like are they in the exact same spot
this time are they going to mix them up
to me i would think the boss room would
feel more satisfying as opposed to be
like
oh well there's possibly nine chests at
all we only got five it's almost like
here's your awards but it kind of feels
bad if you don't get them all
that's not satisfying that's not
satisfying yeah
especially if you're like dude we got
like 10 bosses and we only got like
and you might and you won't get them on
you're like trying to frantically you're
like going crazy trying to find these
last two
after you successfully beat like 10
bosses which is the hard part yeah
they're always words don't feel
satisfying i think the way they should i
think that's more the psychological part
yeah you guys are at the same point i
was just curious i always wanted to know
your thing on that
yeah yeah i mean i never thought too
deep about it but it's always probably
when i'm in the middle of it i'm like
it's like two tints for like finding
chests yeah
because you want maximum reward for the
effort of the kills that you did
yeah i get it just like line up chests
that'd feel great billy you killed like
10 just bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam
bam bam bam bam bam cash out based on
the amount of
okay fair enough referee style of chess
all right crystal
what about the rewards though what from
this thing
you end up getting the crapload of blues
but i'm talking
we get to that i won't get to that oh
those aren't rewards those are stuff you
buy
i know those aren't those aren't rewards
those aren't
wrong words those aren't can we can't we
could use a bright dust though
yeah how much he got i got i'm
i'm low probably three how much you got
that's the real quest forget about what
i mean
[Laughter]
oh my god spending oh what are you
saving this
phone what are we saving this for
nothing caught your eye
oh no like i want the ship mm-hmm yeah
the ship is mean
ship looks good and i want the the
bottom sparrow
you love the box i see i like the top
wow okay the reason i like the bottom
you see more of the light breaking
through and the top looks like those big
gold things which
look a little too over the top for me
anyway it's like a big bulky sparrow
with those big gold things
you can't see the gold as much i like
the sleek bullet with the light coming
up
you see more of the light coming out of
it everywhere enjoy like a little
attraction
see i like the top one i don't know it's
very ornate i like that the little
little design a little curve in the
front
i don't know i like that i like the
taskbar yo the ghosts are larry's
gotta get the golf visor yes
yes and is that a beach hat like what is
going on yeah
i don't know what that the circular
frilly
thingy i don't know i'm see i've seen
hats like that i just don't know
what it's from and then of course
the emotes you're sunning out and i
don't know what the other one is it's
like
is his head on fire is he the son i'm
not sure what it is he's like looking up
it's very very very anime
you know is he super yeah like he's
super saiyan he's about to do whatever
if his fists were clenched that would
even make more sense but if
somebody goes super saiyan it better
damn sure be yellow yeah
interesting color with the green
interesting yeah
yeah the micro mini sparrow i think
that's going to be coming through at
some point if you didn't get the micro
mini make sure you pick that one up
um yeah no i mean every verse is going
to be making some money but the big
eververse stuff is the ornaments
yes so we know you earn the majestic the
majestic you make it magnificent
and you get a white glow cool white glow
actually looks pretty good because it
contrasts really well with the darker
colored armor
the dog stuff yeah but do you want the
colors
well i'm getting them colors and then
and then you get that fourth color in
the fall
yes talk about it let's talk about it
when you buy the ornaments from
eververse we already covered the prices
and all that stuff depending on what
subclass you're using solar arc and void
you're to be orange or you know like sky
blue
or purple though it's going to match
your subclass
the more charged super is the brighter
your armor glows you're looking pretty
cool
we get stasis in the fall they they are
planning ahead
so they have a preview picture of the
solstice armor
with the question dark blue stasis glow
oh so it is official that this is stasis
this color it looks like it yeah because
i would have
an issue with that i gotta look
disappointed
like what do you what color do you want
stasis to be it's gonna be blue or white
like my is my thing and they have arc
right that's what i have to say like
what differentiates this from arc like
that that's my thing
and then the second thing is like you
know you you really wanted i thought i
was going to get a whole new color like
a you know black or whatever
so i guess i was surprised look the blue
light i mean you seem like the trailers
right you are glowing in bluish white
like everything so like doesn't it seem
redundant to have another
blue element does it seem i mean it's
going to be like
sky blue or like light turquoise versus
like a
dark royal blue they're going to be
about as far apart on the blue spectrum
as you can get
now yeah there are other colors there's
greens there's
i mean you could go yellows reds you
could do other colors but for
stasis whitish or bluish freezing
stasis whether it's time related which
would be closer to white in my mind or
blue freezing it's like it's ice it's
going to be blue
how are they going to do the same blue
it's not the same color it's not even
they don't
you put them next to each other it's not
the same blue
of course so that's what we're doing now
every time we we introduce a new
subclass we
oh this this is for fuchsia and this is
lavender and this
like we can do with shades we'll see
like okay so that's something
different like void electricity and fire
it would depend on if they ever did like
say witch queen magenta i'm with you no
which queen which queen i would see a
green it's always green
so if we ever get another darkness
subclass
which i don't know if we ever will get
another after stasis green i'm with you
if we we did green
but but green doesn't fit stasis green
in no way
relates to stasis or ice or freezing i'm
sorry
water is blue see you not you agree
more scientific with it and i get it
you're all letter of the law
to the element of the lore and all i i
feel you
from a redundancy standpoint this feels
lazy i'm just like
really i waited all like i never thought
i was going to get another
you know what you call it some class
thing yeah i was like and bla like while
said fred said it's like while we're
embracing darkness
or kind of but it was like but also
black is a hard thing to do
for have some to give something flare
right like if you have a black subclass
you could have like kind of a shadowy
color but then it's really white versus
black again so you have
they need to do something that's like
gonna
pop in some way so like the green for
the witch queen is something i could
definitely see
i mean you have light if if lightfall is
a thing that's what they're saving black
for
if lightfall has something to it that's
fine but
when it comes to stasis yeah it's like
in my mind i'm not mad about it because
that's exactly what it should be
what color would you want stasis what
would you want it's not going to be like
yellow anything other than another photo
give me what color you want it to be if
it's not blue amy like literally could
have said
anything out of like all right cool
literally like i'm just like
it's forest green well that doesn't make
sense with stasis it's just a different
color
they have to tie it in somehow i'm with
seth right
obviously black is hard to do you know
what i'm saying
great like stick i don't know i i was a
little disappointed yeah i go live
i mean when i saw this i was like oh
baby this is just them talking about it
this ain't it
and then i really read it and i'm like
oh no this this this is it
[Laughter]
i was like i like who was in the meeting
as far as this is blake stasis has been
on locking stuff down in time and you
see people freeze and
shatter i don't know how else to do that
i don't know i don't know how to convey
freezing and ice and stasis and locked
in like a location
better than a a whitish blue
those are your options the white i would
have been there with you but they'd been
there with you
so what would you okay they did the
white glow
as a base color that's your light
yeah that's your light so then they had
to differentiate from the light
we get we get blue i'm rolling with it
but i'm just like okay this is what we
doing
we just every every couple of years you
just do another shade of the same color
and then
that's the new subclass oh no
it's just it was a little weird to me i
was very surprised by this i know it's
like the most smallest probably
insignificant thing i don't know why it
bothers me so much
but it bothered me i was just like all
right whatever this is of
all the things in this class
but this
are we gonna talk about that are we
doing this right now
we we can do whatever but but i got to
just focus on it it was just like
i just want to know how to how to plan a
meeting with like say you're in the
bungee meeting right
and they're like we're going to do this
stasis you know what i'm saying okay
everybody put your ideas in the hat what
we doing with it
and then someone just said yo yo let's
just go with another blue man
let's just go with another blue you know
it it's gonna fit
that it just seemed funny to me oh no i
was very surprised by this
the meaning of that came long before
like hey we're doing stasis all right we
got freezing we got ice right now we had
electricity we had fire we got void
energy
cool now we got to put a void now we got
to put this like glow on here to match
stasis well what do we got
well it's like ice we don't have a lot
of options like they were tied long
before
that meeting ever happened they are the
kids it's not gonna be orange okay
it's not gonna be yellow it's not gonna
be green it's done i've accepted it
but it's just funny that this is the
same team that they could give us
all these variants of shaders right we
have the most
shaders going and this is what this d
like that is funny to me i was just like
okay to be in the realm of electricity
and stasis somewhat related to ice they
made them as far apart as they possibly
could
a dark navy blue versus like light blue
electricity
they made them as far apart as they
probably could in the bluish
we know it would stay next to each other
yeah we will later we need to do that we
need to do that i mean you literally
scroll down the page and you can see
like if you're on if you look at the
animation
the animation one actually probably
shows it better if you look at the
animation it's almost like a
light turquoise teal-ish bluish
and then you come down that is just like
deep royal blue underneath and they're
not that close
i'm just it's stasis it's ice i'm just
kind of on board so that's fine
he's in he's in y'all so last time
we all lost our minds over this whole
hawkmoon debate
yes so i put a poll up on twitter i try
to be as fair with the
phrasing as possible now i will say it
was 75 25 leaning to me but honestly i
did not see the twenty five percent
coming
so white wash no i
well it started like literally like for
a little while it was literally like
ninety two eight percent it slowly
caught up closer
so it started like okay i'm not and then
it like so i'm like
but 25 of the people think i'm crazy i
was like all right so it's just one of
those where
the idea behind some of the exotics like
people were saying you know just break
somebody commented too and they just
want to watch the world burn i forget
who it was
uh they're like bring back icebreaker
and make it even worse or something
they're like they just wanted to watch
the world burn like joker it was too
funny
um but it was just that talk about
exotics coming back
versus either making something new and
is it the right gun and it was just
always the intrinsic nature behind it so
it's just funny to say that like
it was just funny because that was just
like funny when i started i was like oh
and then it got to about 25 i was like
well yeah it's like three quarters with
me there's still there's
a quarter of you guys out there that
think i'm nuts so i'm like all right
i mean for the way the podcast when it
was two to one so
in the grand scheme that was actually
probably pulling the audience pretty
well
oh we would have had four people in here
probably would have been three to one
but that still would have been right so
no i know i'm the minority here um
there's not even a question you know
what i'm saying so
are we doing this or we do oh no i mean
we don't have to go deep diving into it
because i mean
i pose the questions of some people
saying okay so like because the way i
phrased it wasn't hawkman was like so
icebreaker
we know that would break the game and
they do not want ammo regeneration or
anything like that
so if you bring back icebreaker but it
doesn't do what it used to do
should it still be called dead or should
you just make a new sniper so that was
like
because hawkmoon's this like yeah it's
kind of in between i still don't think
it should be but
like icebreakers one we hundred percent
know would break destiny too they would
because we already went through a
whisper they're not gonna like probably
go down the same path so it was just
revokers being sunset at the end of the
season correct also and revoker's going
away same thing anything that makes ammo
out of thin air
you're not huge fans of that so it's
just an interesting topic
i mean at some point if that's my
question crystal that is exactly my
question yeah me too wait let's
details about hawkmoon was revealed they
said
the random they're not going to be doing
random damage nature bullets
i have the quote can i read the quote oh
yeah yes i have the questions
go for it now so um you know this is our
lord and savior luke smith
um god for forgive these sinners i i do
believe in the vision i just want to say
that for the right before i read the
great scripture
before i read
i know they don't believe but i believe
luke but anyway so continuing on with
the great scripture um this is what he
says
before people wonder about luck in the
chamber
talk about let's talk about luck in to
chamber a minute the og hawk moon had
the
interesting and sometimes annoying
property of
all the bullets stacking into one and
then zonking
someone and deleting them in pvp
and then you kind of wonder like what
the hell happened
and that randomness of hawkmoon is kind
of a defining property
emotionally this is exact worth for the
gun
but the team has envisioned a bold new
direction
for hulkboot that's going to move the
randomness
in a different direction off of the
damage that's the killer word right
there
yeah i was like you just ate your own
left right there right there that's the
one that gets them right
so there's no luck in the chamber or
holding aces perks forward right so
that's what the exact thing so the one
you can't call it
hawkmoon you take the damage away and
you take the two perks away they're not
even if like
if the perk isn't even called like
holding aces or whatever it is
why is it even harmful so
according to our great savior luke's man
okay
the essence of the gun is the randomness
is it he calls that the defining
property that's what he says you know
the creators of the guy
and they just want to do something
different so okay you know okay so
our argument aside yes what do you think
they could do with the randomness on the
gun
that's what i'm looking for because i
want to know what you think it could be
i think they can offer it's probably a
new some completely new mechanic
it has to be because at the end of the
day they're moving the randomness in a
different way
what can be random something about the
bullet the bullets are going to do
something else
we gotta wait and see no i will no i
want you to come with something figure
out
no no no just like theoretically yeah
make make hawkmoon without the random
damage but make it still
random something what what can you make
random on that gun that's going to
matter
i think you got to give it a probably a
totally new property
i think you got to give it something
completely
unique or intrinsic to it or a
combination of perks that existed
instead of the damage
i know listen i know how the damage is
for y'all i know i get it
you know what this reminds me of this
remind me of um
remember when we came out and they
nerfed um oh elemental would be
fire crystal that's a great idea that
would be booked
that is what i'm talking about that
would be fire
that'll be fine now i don't know how to
work for a pvp or a void
or that would be fire you want to see a
random energy shot come out of that
thing
that would be fine pve that would be a
nightmare to play around be like oh no
break
break the shield no wrong type break the
break the goddamn shield
and you're getting arc arc void arc and
you're looking for stasis give me a
space this bullet shot
the red eye mag size rate of fire rate
of fire something they could do
make the rpm random okay here's another
thing another exotic i was uh looking at
um being we were in the discussion of
what other exotics that came back and
not
exactly making the rpm random dude dude
yo you know you heard of this gun called
cyros regime
remember serious regime it speeds up it
doesn't random
yeah no i'm just talking about in
general of an existing exotic
yeah came from d1 this doesn't feel like
this is going to be a good argument but
go ahead
no i'm just saying i'm just saying how
things intrinsically change right like
there's some things that did change
obviously we know
how did the process differ but they
added a completely new thing dual speed
receiver did not
exist that didn't exist on cyril's do
you want so that's what i'm trying to
say like
we have to open our minds just a little
bit to see
what they could do that's what i
understand you guys point
i know no point okay hawkmoon aside
they're making a new gun that has some
random thing to it
cool what's your new gun that's the
point
right and that's what we have to wait
and see okay
then make a new gun don't call it
hawkmoon and don't
have random bullets random bullets will
break d2 i get that
random bullets will break d2 we don't
want that we didn't make a new hand
cannon
right but that's all it is so but
they're not doing that so that's over
with so you guys
see you guys say i'm on the high horse
you guys won't let it go
that's the [ __ ] that's the nobody like
trust me i get that the guns coming like
i can't tell them to make something
different i'm just saying
i think theoretically as a design
decision i think it's the wrong decision
right because you want the spirit of the
web you know what's funny y'all think i
don't understand that
and i do you know what i do no i do
i'm just at the acceptance phase you
guys you know i like when someone tell
you no
as a kid you like but i want it but i
want it but i want see i'm already past
that you guys are i want it i want it
it's no no
delay no this is just like this
in general just designed philosophy for
bungie
i would want to sit down with the weapon
designer and say hey we want to make hot
we want to bring hawkmoon back
well we can't bring the damage random
damage back because we feel like that's
unfair for pvp
then me theoretically as a producer
probably over the top goes
that's not hawkmoon somebody in bungie
has had to be probably on
and you know you know you're right and
you know what i said literally which
agreed with forte but yeah were both
going crazy
is that i said this
is marketing this is marketing i i
mean it's a bad way to do that it's
marketing yeah that's not
that no gallagher would be marketing
that's not that doesn't i mean you have
xbox that didn't get it
right it didn't last it was only in year
one that it was there this is not
hitting like a perfect moment for a lot
of people
that this is not a marketing play i just
think this is not the way it is
let me let me tell you why it's a
marketing play one
there's so many people first of all
they're cashing in on the emotion of the
hardcore which is you guys
who are the hawkmoon base who love the
gun just
seeing the aesthetic and yet they're not
going to bring it back so that basically
likes what they got so that's already
not helping we're going to hug this one
out
all right we're going to hug this one
out but it's not happening so what we're
going to do that's like if gcx happens
we'll hug it out
i don't even know if gcx will happen i
really want to thank you bro we need you
i need to meet these people and try i
need to meet the maze i need to meet the
bros like come on obviously way too many
so
here's the thing right i admit
that scummy see i'm with you see y'all
thought i was so against y'all
i'm we lost your mind last time sir
no but y'all y'all kept saying like i
was on a high horse and didn't
understand i've been was
i was in the acceptance if you can
empathize with us saying hey the gun
shouldn't be right
you never said that period no i did i
said yes
yes i did i did listen to it again i did
say it i said i feel you i feel you're
like no you don't understand i'm like no
i
get it i'm just saying this is what it's
going to be the whole we all know we
can't like
change the code i get that i'm just
saying
as a general design philosophy i don't
want them to continue with this i don't
that's why i put the poll out about
icebreaker
if they do an icebreaker that doesn't
regenerate bullets which they shouldn't
do
that means they should not make it in d2
period
and that's what i'm trying to get you
ready for because like remember how you
had to get me ready for sunset
remember how you had to get remember i
was where you was at i was like
no right right that's right so i'm going
to get you where i'm at right
so what it is is they are now getting
you ready this is going to be the new
case listen chat
i don't want more old exotics in the
first place anyway i know i know
oh my god it's like a therapy session
right now and you're not doing it well
we're gonna get
we gonna get there we're gonna get there
so what they're doing now let me tell
you what the new rules of engagement are
with bungie and bringing exotics right
these are the new rules the new rules
therefore they laughing
is if your gun that you want
your prized baby was broken
they're going to market this and bring
it back and change it if it's broken
that's going to be the new rule and this
is going to upset me a lot of new
weapons i i i feel you i feel like
you're right
and you're right then don't give them
the out because the don't look for
their decisions
you know it looks cool when the trailer
for beyond light comes out
and they say hulk moves back and they
get oh you get all
fuzzy inside and you hype and you put
the prior
that works i know what they're doing
that's what this is honestly like if i
see you if i see old exotics in a
trailer i'm typically less hyped
because i want new stuff but they give
us new stuff in fairness they do give us
a lot of stuff
come on they gave us a lot we got a
wither we got an effigy yeah
keep those going all right hold on hold
on let me
let me i got to get forty here's the
thing we got shadow keep
we got divinity we got deathbringer
we got xenophobia i know keep it going
all new undying
we got the only one you don't have to
list off all the new exotics i'm just
saying keep making new stuff
right but the ratio in fairness in
fetish the ratio is about 80 percent new
20 oh well they're running out of old
they've tapped a lot of them out already
if you look over the first couple of
years of destiny yeah that's a lot of
old stuff
facts let me ask you go through the
armor as well that one hurts
yeah slow-mo they mad over the day
that's what they
it's a sacred thing i know what it is
listen
i'm just warning y'all now this is going
to be something they're going to do
if it's a gun like for example like an
icebreaker
or you know what else falls in this
category invective we know invectives
yeah it's not coming right either don't
don't that would break people
bring these things back with down
the new imagining because of the sandbox
because of the balance
and i feel you if you love that gun if
it's my beloved gun like the way i love
it i don't
even love some of these guns
it just shouldn't be like if you're
going to make
a perk that changes the way said weapon
works
just make a new why is it so i know you
have to go through the art models and
stuff so there are some assets in there
but they make a lot of exotics already
either bring like bring a gun back that
fits
or don't bring it back like no time to
explain that was never that powerful in
the first place so they probably don't
have to change that maybe i should do
this since you know another thing your
option
is you could boycott and don't use the
gun i probably won't
oh you're standing on your square
if the randomness isn't for damage and
it's just like oh i don't i
on it so i can't figure out what the
randomness is going to be
all right we gonna pout and not try
that's what we gonna do dude i'm gonna
let other other people probably gonna
have it long before i get it unless it's
a quest so i don't even i don't even
know you to associate yourself with
hawkmoon in this fashion
this is another thing that's funny about
no but if it was icebreaker i'd be doing
the same thing if it was infected i'd be
doing the same thing if you're gonna
bring back a weapon
and it's not like it should be make a
new model a new name and a new set of
perks
that's the whole point of like a new
exotic that functions in a different way
what they say to starter i feel you look
man i'm just trying to get y'all to the
acceptance phase that's
all i'm there just come on the water's
nice dude i can't change the programming
i get
that i can accept it i'm also just
saying
for future iterations i don't want them
to continue this either
i can't change hawkmoon okay all right
at least we got that because you never
admitted that thank you
i i'm i'm not gonna change i'm not gonna
sound like i can change change
i was coming i thought y'all was going
to change.org i
can't change bungie's mind despite your
jokes
it was serious oh i've never once said i
can change their mind i just think as a
design philosophy
for exotic weapons ever that shouldn't
be the way they're done
so if they think about invective they
think about icebreaker leave them in the
past
make something new what about i gotta
shout out which queen hold on
uh what if they made it like stores
charges and kills and then be able to
one shot guardian that would remove the
randomness
with the damage but it has one shot
potential so it has a chance to like
store something up that might have a
chance to use it occasionally
random element champion shots like
if you get champion shots you actually
got to make exotics and champions work
together that's a whole different
argument
what if they did that i don't see what
they did if they had some spawn they had
elements on it
it was a little intrinsic champion stuff
what random champion oh i fired no
that's a barrier nope that's unstoppable
but you'd have it but you have it you
could not depend on that in the grand
master nightfall when your life is on
the line
it's the spirit of the weapon no
you'd have two random stunning problems
i'll be fired
come on come with me cover the water's
nice no you're saying
like a random stasis bullet a random
overload shot or
random barrier no that's a terrible idea
that's terrible
that's awful you would never depend on
that in a in a grand
in a situation where that mattered you
would never depend on that ever
all right so what if it's two random
bullets of the same so what if it's like
yesterday which queen no which queen if
they bring back whisper after sunset and
doesn't refill ammo from observe will
you be mad correct yes i will be mad
don't bring back whisper like that leave
in the past i'm not by his name he's
about the purity
the sacredness he don't don't mess with
them don't mess with them you know this
is making new [ __ ]
is that so hard but they do
they bring this these one d it's like
they're like sacred scriptures it's like
don't you dare touch this gun that it's
just it's fun
i'm literally saying that for all of
them by the way i know you're fighting
you're fine
all the exotics from d1 treat them all
the same if they're not gonna come back
in a similar fashion
thorn was a variation but still had the
dot over time
that was an evolution not a completely
different path for the weapon
that's the difference in that one and
that's why it matters
no i i've been on this i'm just trying
to get him over to where i'm at i'm just
trying to
get him to the acceptance i'm just
saying and then
it's going to happen i just don't want
to see it keep happening that's
literally all hawkmoon is going to
happen
we'll see how it goes i'm not going to
be thrilled about it but
anyways last point i will say is that
this is the kind of thing that companies
do
they test the waters they see
right and once they get go if it goes
over okay
expect to see it expect to see more of
it i won't think it'll be like
super frequent because they're going to
run out of exotics obviously yeah you
know what i'm saying
but um the reality is listen at some
point you know galahad coming
back no you know
don't do it yes come in come into what
is that i see i'm traveling
i'm trying to mentally prepare you see
that's a mistake
they reissued it it was the big thing in
your one they reuse it in year three you
can't do a triple issue
come on bro that's we are normal with
the numbers
right they're no longer with the numbers
they are by themselves
they do not have anyone they don't have
daddy hold on
we got 47 people in there if you guys
have just lurking i'm calling you for
like five seconds you can go back to
lurking
if you want to see gallo horn come back
put a one if you don't want to see gallo
horn come back
put a 2. i would do a poll but i'd have
to switch screens so for now just in
chat
one you want to see gallihorn come back
two i don't
black iron man no that's hot but
well they should bring the weapon back
random and damage forte we get it but
it's coming brother it's coming so you
just gonna have to get over this
you gonna have to get to the accepting
phase too you guys are like
scorned upset lovers like i get it it's
not
you know your baby i understand
he said two if they don't have wolf pack
right
he's hanging he's an angry man
oh
similar to my poll on twitter it's about
75
twos and about 25 ones shout out to
british i am having a ball
and shout out shout out to uh a guest
appearance in chat by the way
who we got who we got go look
about the fifth vote the fifth why am i
missing this paul
forte gmd witch queen cognito
yeah we'll figure it out we'll figure it
out we'll bring it up
yeah i get it i get it it's you know
listen
i think that's the path they're on until
maybe development you know they get a
little stuff these things are easy to
make man
it's easy to do one cash i call it a
cash grab you do the one cash grab joint
per season that's gonna hit the
nostalgic fields
to get a little bit of that old school
base to come back
and is it is it right is it a little bit
scummy absolutely i'm never gonna say
it's not
uh do i understand what you're saying to
the letter of the law if especially if
it's my gun
like i guess sleeper would be that blind
be yours
yeah yeah they bring sleeper back and
it's an auto rifle
see that you're being ridiculous that's
the point it ain't that much of a change
but i see what you're saying though as
far as the intrinsic nature see that's
funny i
understand you guys but you guys were so
emotional you didn't want to hear it
i was never once been quite like that
yeah
i've never seen that from y'all i was
like wow this is
this is a big deal
but i believe in i believe in luke man
luke forgive them they gonna be okay
they just gotta touch and see what it do
lou i'm telling you man have faith for
luke he gonna he gonna make it right
oh yeah
yeah y'all love it it's gonna be a fun
one we'll see what happens though let's
see what happens hopefully it's
something cool but i will say this
i will give you all this i got us on the
record in fairness
if it comes back and it is absolute
trend
if it is really not effective
then yes you get every right to give
luke the business on that you know what
i'm saying because it's like yo you
should have left it alone
it was it was fine how it is and you now
you made it worse so you made it a joke
fine but he's the pressure's on they
know how you guys feel
come on you gotta admit that they know
you guys especially datto the biggest
you know one of the biggest guys in the
community that's his favorite gun people
love this gun they've got to do it i got
a little faith maybe maybe i'm too
optimistic i got a little faith they're
gonna do something
a little cool something a little
intrinsic a little different that we
didn't see and maybe like oh wow all
right this is
it's not the same different but still
cool that's what i'm saying
we will only time we can tell man all
the time i just like if it's got
different perks and stuff on it give it
a different name and model that's just
that's my opinion you're you're open to
seeing if they evolve it right
hopefully that's up to you oh my god
quarter what classifies effective
i'll
one time i used it and i put it away
black iron man blind [ __ ] not every idea
lucas is a good one
remember guardian games and saying that
stranger storyline it's over back in the
day wow you're coming hard right now
please guys
after all luke did for you you guys we
don't know
bungie listens to this podcast shout out
if y'all do y'all are
y'all are amazing uh yeah it's all out
of love right
now because i got faith invite me to the
tools
i'm the goddess yeah i'm the one who
backed you up on sunsetting this is one
weapon mine's bigger so
he got this i got you luke
all the time we pick different hills to
die on for bungie
so so we have some some differing
opinions but this is the way you go
where the
apologies now this way you gonna win
the day they announce exotics get sunset
oh god
i gotta be where you at i'm not i don't
know
and then you'll be like nah this is what
i'm talking about come the water's nice
this
when they sunset exotics man
the world will i dread that day because
there's a part of me
i'll it bit you know it that
i want to see your face they taking your
exotics they putting power numbers on it
it's over for your dick and i'm gonna be
like you know what
i gotta eat that one
slo-mo just do it do slow-mo says sunset
all exotics do it
come on slow you were doing so well you
put so well that you're on my side
you're antagonizing the right people
no don't don't do this one no they start
phasing out some of the oh they would do
it in time i would bet
maybe they last for years but if you get
that's like in like the six years like
at it's it's something i could see top
like thank you
all exotics i would never say all but i
could definitely see a time the way
they're doing it
i could see it see i'm not ready
we've established
you're supposed to be on my side and
antagonizing 14. you're not supposed to
be attacking see i can't remember who
replied to my tweet and was just like
ads bring it back and make it like twice
as bad let's just watch everything burn
somebody was just like ready just to
just just set things on fire and watch
it just grabbing probably emotionally
get me would be like
i'll break prime whisper because of what
was
required to do those yeah and the
multiple runs and getting the cat lit
uh that would hurt that would hurt
that would hurt that would be a sad day
for me the whisper would go first by
time
then the next year you'd see outbreak
and some stuff go
it's just slow i don't like to show in
your voice bro i don't like to join you
it goes both ways that's all i'm saying
this is the payback
the game has to continue to evolve
apparently i've got to get on board with
the evolution of re-issued exotics
and you got to get on board with the
change of times we both got to roll with
the punches
fact that's why you're my brother that's
my bro we emotionally over the
funniest things oh man
so fun we're in a weird time guys it is
so
like destiny is in this weird spot where
we sit here and like
think about everything that could be
coming we spend half an hour debating
over one weird dumb exotic reissue just
because we're dumb and joke about it but
it's like
we have a lot of time to think about
this stuff because beyond light was
delayed
we have you know we have the european
aerial zone
that's a month long now if you're gonna
do all three characters it's probably
gonna take you all month unless you just
like know life it which
those people i'm oh yeah man i don't i
don't into you but on the other side
you're like
so september and then windows festival
so this ends the start of september
festival starts in october
so we got september's nothing
yeah it's looking they're looking
september's avengers no
all right what's in september we have
the we have the road map
nothing zero so when does um
solstice end solstice ends november 10th
oh so this goes all the way no social
sins uh
no sorry i was thinking um the season
september 8th
oh september and then season of the
rivals if they updated the calendar now
should show festival lost so you have
september 8th to october 6th
[Music]
and then festival lost ends october 6 to
november 3rd
and then you have one week until beyond
light comes out
and it's just it's weird because it's
weird
is the way the see maybe festival's just
going to be ongoing
and then just somewhere in those weeks
they start wrapping up the seasonal
content
because when you have the evacuation
missions even if they do them once a
week that's still
let's see sometime in october so yeah
september 8th
granted bitched and complained about six
months of downtime and i'm looking at
one month and like
oh no four weeks what am i gonna do yeah
like one month we'll be fine keep
working on your seals keep working on
your titles keep working on all your old
stuff like cognito got his
master worked uh outbreak once you were
doing it yeah
there's a lot of stuff you can do that's
just kind of the thing
now in my opinion you could take the you
know
festival make it a little longer but
honestly solstice they could extend
that's the one i wish they would extend
to be completely honest though you know
i think it was um
crystal that actually got me in mind
thinking about it do you think with the
old cadence
where september was supposed to be
beyond light do you think
that they were going to sneak in one of
those
like classic in
mission okay not with prophecy not even
would not fathom it with prophecy being
this season
no thing because i'm like it's probably
too short a window that's why and i
can't see them doing anything now
because this is scramble time
to just extend so yeah they're just
they're they need time to finish which
is fine take the time you need
but yeah they did infer when they
they made the announcement that this was
getting delayed to november
they did infer we have a couple of
surprises it's probably gonna be light
you know saying but
i am curious to see because they still
got that gap where they didn't account
for content that they now have to
account for
you can't literally do i mean they could
literally just do
banners and not be pissed off but no but
i mean like in fairness to them can you
always ask them to be like
we need to extend the game to build this
thing but you got to fill this with
something no they don't
that's the key is like but what do they
do is it just
going to be iron banner yeah is it going
to be so we're going
every other week valor bonus uh infamy
bonus
iron banner that that's all i see
i don't see i was just wanting to know
if there was something they could do
that's not necessarily
new designing new assets that was
existing that
i was just thinking i don't think no
i don't see anything no i like i'd if
they had something like that
it's got a certain place if it was going
to be in september when it's the
downtime that's when beyond light is
launching
i know what i would like them to do what
would be cool
is if they start doing like all right
you know how we got
um double valor weekend dub you know
such such what they need to do double
double nightfall weekend like double
material weekend
so you get in there and you'll be like
yo golf balls is dropping
you know charge of dropping because
these materials y'all
these materials get a little rough i've
been massive working a lot i've been
doing a lot of stuff
like it it's rough when you get to eight
up from eight to ten
it's it's rough they won a lot they want
a lot of resources that's why most of my
stuff lives at eight or nine
yeah like or seven like this would be a
cool
way because think about this when the
nightfalls are always with the few times
that they are broken
everyone's in yeah everyone's running
there they even try to ramp up the
grandma
they need to you can't make new assets
so
now just increase some you know increase
some rewards give some people
a chance to farm a couple of these
things i don't think that way pit of
heresy drop masterwork stuff that
actually has
good stats on it hello make prophecy
drop
master worked armor if you go into like
pve activities are dropping high stat
masterworks and lots of golf balls and
charts just everywhere from
just like it's raining currency like i
don't know like you that's stuff they
could do
now granted the pit of heresy has been
in there for a while so apparently
that's a little harder than i think but
in my head it's not what do i know
um but yeah i mean take nightfalls and
get that in the rotation
yes that would be a nice tease to stuff
they could start doing in the fall
because that stuff they need to do more
because yeah they do have the you know
your crucible ranking your infamy your
your valor your glory all of those have
like rankings you can earn
there's nothing on the pve side no
granted there's plenty of crap to do in
pve don't get me wrong
not saying pvp doesn't have stuff they
could always use more but
in in turn yeah what do you get out of
those find
double the rewards on that side
absolutely i fully support that
yeah that that would give a nice shot in
the arm everyone
loves those weeks when you you know your
video goes out he makes a video like yo
now's the time to get in there y'all
you know this is dropping this and you
know especially like i said shards and
all that stuff
golf ball golf balls especially where do
you even get those at
night falls or trials chest i think i've
never gotten a golf ball really
never no yeah it's master night falls or
trials now shout out to black iron man
crystal all right pc that's [ __ ] yeah
we got the basketball falls i can hold
if i want to farm them let me hold like
50 golf balls dude stop keeping me at 10
be like well you can only hold 10. so if
you do spend your 10
then you got to go back to the activity
what if i want to play the crap out of
these nightfalls and store some up
because you guys make them hard enough
to get i remember when they mentioned be
like oh we're going to make currencies
easier that's not uh these currencies
still
and that's my issue i think bigger with
the armor
is this whole instance of mods have a
very expensive cost the seasonal mods
have an even more
i did a whole video over the damn
artifact that's a different animal um
and just the idea that as you said i'm
afraid to master work because you've
never got one
so then if you do masterwork the ones
you get for a season you only get like
three sets of armor yeah you get a
random roll out of it
you're like oh i got a better random
roll now i don't know how much you get
back when you dismantle one i've never
disbanded
i don't think i've ever gotten a golf
ball back no but i don't think i've ever
dismantled a 10 piece yet
i have enough armor from pit of heresy
that i probably could
yeah you should test it but i doubt i
don't think you do
to my understanding is i don't think you
get a golf ball back which is
get to like nine nine nine yeah the
currency the limitations still bugged me
yeah a lot of that stuff should
definitely be higher i said no it
doesn't
he said doesn't give you a goal doesn't
give one back so then again
so if you do put the golf ball in and
you're like i just got a slightly better
stat rule well
[ __ ] like yeah exactly i mean that's the
whole point is to continue to farm to
try and get that like
oh i got something 63 stats and it
shifted it just a little bit more to the
build that i'm going for
well now i got to spend all this more
currency then i got to go find grand
master nightfall groups again
it's that's the weird place that i guess
armor is in for me is because i don't
put the effort in
because i feel if i do commit i'm not as
rewarded and especially
and this is where sunsetting does come
in especially
that yeah because now we're going to
invest all this stuff
to you know for are we really going to
invest all less than a 1260
right you almost now want to only like
i'm almost in there like if it ain't 13
10 13 60
no yeah ain't investing you know rivals
only basically yeah
like that it's it's so it's like if you
want us to
you're doing this sunsetting thing to
get us to do fresh and new
okay if you wanted to do fresh and new
then you got to give more materials
because the materials y'all hoarded is
not good enough that's just a fact
and this would be the time now during a
dead period
to reward the people who are still loyal
to the game during a dead period
because we're giving you time to do
beyond light
so in this case yo here's an ascended
shard weekend
here's what you call it weekend like
golf ball weekend like yo
come in there you get double rewards
that's give us some fun man
people will get in there man people will
get in there for at least a weekend
and rock out they need to do more of it
yeah like
that's the whole point is like the game
does get kind of fun
when like you do go you know i have 10
energy
on everything because i have a full pit
of heresy set
but i can't even like use that going
into the fall
so like my full pit of heresy said that
i'm using now to solo flawless like
prophecy which i did
because i can use it and i can mix some
of those things up i can't use it in the
fall because
yeah the tier 10 stuff and that's like
stuff costs a lot and i understand
certain things have values but again as
i've said before
make some of this high level stuff have
12 energy on it but don't make those
golf balls so impossible to find
what if you do turn in a package every
so often like every blue moon you can
make it
less than one percent of shacks make it
like exotic make it like an exotic
every blue moon golf ball you're like oh
okay
sweet i got one cool i got a bonus i can
use it like yeah
if you made them come up every so often
more frequently
people wouldn't be hoarding like i hoard
them because i'm like
if i fully master worked everything not
everybody can farm these nightfalls like
right you know gmd's in chat he's
probably sitting there could have like
900 of these things as many stuff as
he's carried people through
he could have all the stuff in the world
but i can guarantee you 95
of the player base is not like him and
they barely have enough and they might
be afraid to use them or if they do
they've probably regretted it at some
point in them
so far but they made a good point brush
made a good point
it's like you feel like you're being
punished for grinding it is true it is
true they're putting the cap on it
they're being stingy and they also put
the cap on it
so yeah they got they got to work on
that gotta work on that man
sure and i guess this is where it's like
they're holding a lot of information on
beyond light because i know things are
still in flux
but they've really got to start sharing
some stuff over beyond light we're in
august now
i know we got august september october
we got three months
but late they push them back i know
they're
holding some but i mean there's some
questions people need like tassie
sitting there writing articles like
how is transmog going to work do i need
to hold on to the armor
or is it going to be stuff that if i've
earned it once i can
do whatever thing mechanic they make
then i can turn around and use that as
an ornament
how is that do i need to keep the armor
to like plug it into some machine so
that gives me the transmog ability or
if i ever earned it like there are some
what's gonna happen to my four
currencies for the planets going away
those are like should i go to spider and
farm those things
or should i like start dumping those
into other stuff to buy
the materials that matter their noses to
the grindstone right now they're trying
to make this date
we they they're very good about that
stuff i mean it's just going to be a
while i honestly think
august is going to be a wash for that
kind of we may get light kind of stuff
i'll be surprised if we start getting
preview stuff this early
i think september i mean september is
the downtime they'll fill it with that
maybe yeah
grind your hearts out and solstice when
solstice is done
right our down month will start filling
your heads with the new stuff
yeah they're just stretching this out
they're just in a situation where they
have no choice
and that's just where we at you know and
you know i guess like you said
play at your leisure do what you got to
do get stuff done that you want to do i
think now is the time
there's some great you know stuff that
you can start farming
start prepping start getting your
exotics start doing
these raids you know what i'm saying as
far as if you want your your um
what you call your moments of triumph
and all that stuff and i think now is
the time this is my motto
be optimal now is the time to look at
your bills
look at your vault see like i had to
make some tough decisions like it was
emotional for me to delete the old one
that i got the shirt from this
the old suit but i was like look no no
now the new one's announced it's gonna
be a full year
this terrible stat armor that looks good
got to go
you know so bro look got me i'm up to
about
you'll laugh i'm like up to 60
masterwork call that's huge for me
60 bastards oh 60 course nice yeah it's
like huge so i'm like all right cool
i started cleaning that up and now also
with time to be even let's bother our
advice
time to be more greedy with god rolls
so if you got that cold denial and you
like damn it would have been cool
if it were to have feeding frenzy and
this and this masterwork
now's the time you got all the materials
you got all the all you know the things
go in there roll the dice that's what
i've been doing i got me a cold denial
now
feeding frenzy range and um swashbuckler
because there's no there's no what you
call it i got multi-kill on mine
rocking and rolling right you know what
i'm saying um same thing all the uh oh
um
the shotgun i've been doing the i got
the guy roll i fought for the god roll
um smg i got my trench barrel back
with a real close up gotcha ikelos is in
there like
time to be greedy and optimal if you do
that
you are all your 1360s lined up you're
gonna be ready to go you know what i'm
saying because you're gonna have a lot
of that best stuff that's
that's the joy i've been kind of having
in the game
lately just really being greedy like
okay i got all this material let's have
some fun let's see
you know hit slots see what we got oh
yeah i mean i got my fallen guild team
perfect roll
check that box nice um
i have a really good forward path
actually but i will definitely say
i gotta be a better floyd pad what you
got uh feeding frenzy multikill
i think hold on i gotta look i got
feeling frenzy squash and i'm having fun
with
i'm having a lot of fun with squash
pokemon beating frenzy multi-kill
tactical mag and hit mark with
it's like reload speed it's not perfect
but i mean
it comes up to iron banners like farming
for weapons in iron banner not easy
but i will definitely say in in pvp
bulls remedy man that's sidearm yeah kai
swan
it's something about everyone's it's
it's one of those guns you always say
that everybody else can use it except
you
everybody else kills me with it i use it
i'm garbage
i'm not great with it i'll be honest but
i've sat there and fired it at a wall
and its recoil direction is 94.
it is dead vertical if you literally
don't move and you full
put it shoot it at a wall it's straight
up i think it's the sight that
you know what i'll i'm a breech-like guy
it's something about bri like i got a
breech light with
um demolitionist and vorpal and i just
love this thing man
i am just tearing it's i think it's the
sight it's something about the weapon
placement it's just i'm just terrible
it's just me i know it's a me issue i am
just terrible with that guy oh no i mean
well i mean granted cool guy put out a
video that you know 180s are not in a
good spot
but everybody was in that whole like hey
trust trust trust i'm like
i hated trust it's a 180 but i hate all
180s typically for me do not feel great
so it's
i mean i get killed with last dance i
don't know it's just for me it's like
it's a nice because it's a full auto one
so if you're airborne as a titan i don't
have the hover which so mine typically
sucks
but i still can kind of hope to like
maybe veer their direction while i'm
jumping with a full auto so
it's been it's been fun but it's like i
i got it and like i'd use like lonesome
or whatever
whatever reasonable sidearm i had to get
it in the first place but once i've got
it i'm like
it's actually pretty good yeah it's
actually not that bad it's not that bad
man
yeah i've been doing that but messing
with different bills i've dusted off
um a couple of exhausts uh izanagi and a
couple other stuff
messing with around with a lot of
different loadouts stuff like that just
being optimal bang
yup cat daddy team no sleep you already
know that's very
my buddy he's the cat daddy's a die he
he never played d1 he just started
playing d2
now went from to hardcore
in the matter of three weeks i've
watched he's been transformed
into playing destiny more than me so
salute the cat daddy that he is nice to
see people get hooked on this thing this
long into it
welcome to the club baby yeah
[Laughter]
salute that's the hobby right dude
but yeah like iron banner is not bad you
got your pinnacle rolls from that but
i'm like am i going to grind
everything up i don't i don't know i've
been trying to do other stuff as well
um yeah i don't even care about
pinnacles anymore to be honest i was
like i mean i'll like my hunt
my titan's almost 1060. like i'm 1059.7
or eight or whatever i'm close enough
that i need literally two rolls
some 10 59 so any pinnacle even the plus
ones are
going to be 1060. i just so i just need
rng to hit and we have so much time
but i will tell you also like when i
went and did my whole 20 minute video
over the artifact
and i was like i wonder who's the
highest power level i've been seeing
some guy pop up on twitter
and i looked he is 1114.
his artifact is plus 54.
that's ridiculous but i also feel really
bad because that does you nothing
doesn't nothing doesn't you you need to
feel strong
yeah i need to feel strong like so part
of it was like when it comes to the
artifact for one
you could literally get rid of the first
three columns of the artifact
yeah first one you could put
anti-barrier
overload and unstoppable just make those
like weapon perks you can pick from just
like any weapon perk we have
yes pick what weapons you want them
available on that slot's gone
second one all they're doing is changing
the cost of either reload speeds
or anything else so literally just hey
seasonal patch notes these mods are
cheap this season
done that column's gone third one
glimmer that one's sucks
just get the whole column out whole
thing gone just
pick it up and the reason i will never
use it i'm never gonna go through the 12
and then be like hey i'm actually really
long glimmer maybe i could go you know
kill a whole lot of taking stuff and get
some back
i'm never gonna reset my artifact to do
that and i think paul said this before
let me unlock every mod the dude
54 i think has earned to have every mod
available
but like it's a great like as you keep
playing especially if you get up to like
plus 20 like the mods go quicker than
your levels because they're
the mods are linear let me unlock every
mod because like the end column is the
big powerful stuff
listen i feel you but you know they how
they get what they balance no no but no
that's not the whole
like the whole thing on the end they're
all six or seven they all work in the
same slot
so you could have access to them all
right so i'm never gonna be able to use
like
all the different bricks any more than i
would so like having access to all of
them would let me have variety of builds
right
and again they're only three months
anyway that's another thing
if you're going to make all these mods
over the seasonal artifact be like hey
if some that are liked or fan favorites
how about they may become permanent
nothing has become permanent from the
artifact
where'd that whole little message go hey
if you guys like them we'll bring them
into the game later for any nothing's
coming oh yeah
yeah yeah they did say that yeah
nothing's permanent yet how many people
if oppressive darkness
if it was just a permanent thing would
probably run that
yeah i mean that and um the sword won
last season
you commit to swords but you use that
mod that was like six or seven energy
but you're harder to kill with a sword
right so it makes swords in a pve smash
world
viable i don't know what kind of fire do
you have that uh the mod
for the rocket launcher for every charge
of light it gives you the action see
that one is the charge of light stuff is
permanent
those you won't get those who won't get
rid of it's the seasonal stuff is more
what i mean but yeah those are i like
that i know what you're talking about
bro
two-tailed fox with that yeah that's
that's a lot two-tailed is back that's a
build-out player did i see john
did a video i'm like damn i could have
did a video because i knew about that
that joint is
crazy yeah if you got that that rocket
launcher
um mod and you have charged with light
it
literally feels like old-school rocket
it's probably
arguably one of the best dps weapons in
the game now so yeah dust off that two
uh two tail man another one yeah
well somehow would just solstice in us
do here
we rambled on for another two hours and
you guys made it through chat you guys
have been fantastic today
amazing i've been loving all the
comments and stuff you guys have been
keeping us on our toes calling both of
us
out making sure we're playing fair
uh you guys are awesome by the way i
just want to shout you guys out
kicking off this august you know the
little chat was lit
show but in the grand scheme of things
you got anything else
nah man i mean like i said this just at
the end of the day
like i said be optimal have fun
do what you got to do yes set
set the data set the data right and then
from there
yo just go play some other games get
some stuff done
get some stuff done comment on your
resets knock out what you gotta knock
out
but also get your um yo start raiding
and start playing trials y'all
come on time this is time now what are
those things
and play what here you speak of exactly
if you want the cool shirts the cool
stuff you know what i'm saying just have
some fun man there's
some cool activities in the game you're
gonna reward you for and remember some
stuff is going away
so you gotta gotta lock that down and
these are the chance that giving us the
rewards
which queen i feel you on the solo stuff
i feel y'all i feel you
i'm telling you i mean if you're on pc
well i can say lfg is really cool
i'm telling you there's times where some
of my clan makes so you know when i jump
right on in there
you know it's good shots it's not all
bad no it's not all bad you'll find
something the trials go away
geeka monkey so yo you gonna stop with
the sunset try now you go too far
now you go too [ __ ] sunset and trials
would you
try yes i would last but i i would
actually jump in there with you
the problem is one i think you said your
platform was
xbox or pc i forgot because it was a
piece of pc
yeah if it's pc it's a little spooky but
i'll jump in there with you i don't care
actually doing trials tomorrow i gotta
i'm waiting to do trials till
solstice starts because if i got to get
seven wins and maybe hey let's wait i'm
gonna do all that at the same time
i'm gonna get my seven wins while trying
to go around because correct i'm not
doing it twice
the word i use we don't do things for
free
[Laughter]
so we won't you out here charging now no
no not
money i meant like this my word like
man you got to buy him a pizza i don't
know something
pizza don't do it for free what i mean
is from an optimal standpoint right we
talked about multitasking
doing multiple things at once to get
objectives done
so we wait on trials until solstice drop
then we get credit for this pain that we
putting in
and also grabbing bounties doing that
that's what i mean optimal that's what i
mean we don't do it free gotta do it you
know get a reward for it
that's what i'm saying yeah don't do it
now
raid now yeah right now raid all you
want
do your dungeons do your solos flawless
yeah
facts so yeah man
all right uh gotta figure out who we're
gonna raid
got a couple options uh ob katie cat we
got zoey who's uh let's do zoey she was
on here
yeah oh [ __ ] announcement quick before
you know i was just gonna say it's like
so if you guys got an opinion of who we
should read throw them in chat
um but let me know and we'll figure out
who we're gonna read when we get done
but
uh yeah i think that's where we will
wrap this thing up so cog whatever you
got
man floor is all yours hit him man
listen you already know add more
cognitive on twitter
first of all chat yeah amazing salute to
y'all like this this was a lot of fun
you know saying always calling us i was
hilarious but um yeah so
i like it on twitter on ironworldpodcast
youtube this week whether on youtube or
twitch
we will have the iron harvest developers
it's a cool
real-time strategy game if you're into
real-time strategy it will be the
developers
versus us wish us luck are you playing
against them
we're playing against the developers of
the game it's games in open beta right
now on steam oh you're going to die you
can check it out
we might die a horrible death oh yeah
we're going to go out fight find
someone's iron harvest dads versus the
iron lords
come check us out should be a 3v3 will
be fun saturday
12 p.m eastern so that'll be on iop
and then sunday back to our regular
scheduled program with the online
podcast
1pm eastern we will have a fun fun show
one of the devs that we have from our
harvest will come back on and we'll also
have
hogue law bring him in hogue is going to
be talking about the legalities
and the contractual nature of sony
exclusivity deals
it will be very very fun so um check
that out we have some fun topics shout
out the lady also sup
yeah lady office cool people i was like
i'm sure you have to pick his brain on
the
x-cloud crap going on too yeah we gotta
talk about
that we gotta talk about apple not
playing nice we gotta talk about all the
latest engagements there's a couple
yikes moments out there
in the world yeah so that's what we got
but that's what i want to shout out
and again you already know about the
last word y'all here you already know
about that
and shout out to with your coach shout
out to my boy king he'll have some king
of the statues up some other fun stuff
up on the channel so i appreciate the
support that is always
love that's what i got yeah you guys
know me i'm still working through goes
to sushima um
got my butt whooped by the dual so
hopefully i can make a little faster
progress because that was most of that
night it was
brutal but i mean play it on try it on
lethal i tell you that so
you can change it in game try it on
lethal you can always switch it right
back
so it's not a big deal but if you try it
on lethal because you're more powerful
too when you're against a lot of like
the
showdown type of stuff yes and you're
like
dude i just beasted this like it feels
good but i can promise you there's some
stuff gonna mess you up too
so try it just let me know how you feel
on that one for
good you gotta give it a feel while
you're in it because i don't want you
like do a second playthrough like
try it when you're in it and just mix it
up in fact that you said i could switch
on a fly that i could do that yeah
but that's where we get in that long
overdue lore episode
that's what they're asking us lore from
us
i don't know if we're going to claim to
be the experts maybe we can try and get
another
expert on faster yeah we're working on
we're working on another loremaster
definitely for sure yeah yeah uh there's
a couple i could think of
there's a couple there's a couple
working on yeah there's there's a couple
i could think of so laura's always cool
so there's two i could probably thank
you for that
yeah if we do a lawyer i was like we had
life dude
it was fantastic three hours we stole
him for milan
evan both of those would be good so yeah
let's see about those both of those
would be really good wants to step in
and crystal's got these guys
crystal knows everything crystal yeah
you get to fill us with all the samurai
knowledge and everything else you got in
this game you were
yeah you got you got knowledge crystal
reads a lot
i got a feeling batman absorbs
information and it sticks like one of
those lucky photographic memories
so we got the rolodex but yeah for me
you guys know where to find me twitch
twitter youtube right here i've been
trying to work on
youtube stuff so if you guys do see a
video come out the views are helpful
trying to get my numbers up there
a goal sir aren't you close to a certain
number
yeah so i'm about 700 away from 50k so
i've been trying to climb for that one
so i'm trying
trying to get to the 50 but also trying
to get just the views up for the month
because i'm trying to go after
a specific thing so if you guys do see a
video pop you know play a couple in the
background for me you know send some
love
um yeah overall you guys are fantastic
always a good chat thank you guys very
much gotta end it in style
uh so we're gonna raid zoey once we wrap
this thing up but guys today it has been
awesome
august 7th episode 115. uh
guessed it mega we'll definitely get a
reschedule and get her back on no big
deal hey life happens it's all good
uh so thank you guys for tuning in and
for this episode
it has been the last word